previously on hand stimulator something
else I think
pospos let's do crossbows when its
market Lamarr what the [ __ ] because I'm
finally someone recognizes that I'm just
better Oh for God
oh sweet ever-loving Jesus this is not
possible it is totally possible you just
gotta have skill and have read many
articles on crossbows where's my can you
guys see my arm no no oh god what
happened to you
why'd you do that you know in some arm
troubles there bud woo i cocked it what
the hell how but yeah God's name would
you possibly have accomplished that I
cocked it it's not actually possible I
did it I'm currently just trying to make
sure that in case I ever do successfully
do that all of my bolts are not on the
ground frames no no no that's an old
joke
[Laughter]
cuz I'm loaded and ready to go doubters
get get the crab oh that's what you
are you to shoot me okay that's actually
kind of aimed at me yeah no stop talking
we already gave you grenade you don't
get to know how everything works I know
how everything works when you've been
around the block like I have you start
to know things well been around the
block I've been around the block marker
you gonna shoot me or what hey hey stop
the peanut gallery to me and I'll just
like snatch it like lightning reflexes
yeah yeah I'm not joking once you get to
the point where you're actually aiming
it's real weird
it stops behaving what your arm wants
it's just completely wrong like too
heavy
yeah your arms yeah wait no I'm gonna
frost that's the entire joke of the game
okay time for you it's not Oh get me Hey
right I'm ready to catch it no come on
what the [ __ ] it what what come on
okay right no too hard
god damn tell me before you shoot cuz I
want to look alright okay it's coming no
that's not lined up what it's when I
switch arms it just jostles
right here here comes death I'm assuming
it's the big red button all right I got
it loaded did you die okay mark hey Wade
your arms almost better there are
[ __ ] crossbow fellers Oh mark just
wait till I aim this at you oh yeah let
me hold my crossbow what pinkies up yeah
no that bolt does not look on there yeah
you're right yeah that bolts weird yeah
hang on okay good luck
no I'm not even looking dad you are I
don't see anything I'm actually blind
here comes death spitting I can't I
can't reach it there here comes death
spitting
oh just you guys wait once I've done
touching myself well I think way would
be easier to shoot at I'm gonna shoot
away hang on you do that I it's kind of
an equal fraid either you for me so I'm
gonna do whatever feels right totally
nothing's happening
but before you hey God yeah let me do
wait first take on okay yeah do it do it
I hope there's a drop on this air Yeah
right there Oh
finish me I can't [ __ ] how hard you
have to not at all it's super light
won't do it well it's not cocked all the
way on my screen oh did I miss
yeah with upper left of me all right
I've got once you gotta hold the bow
actually this is kind of manageable yeah
it's not so fast upon the bow is the
hard part
yeah it's wait I don't know what your
problem is this game is flawless
so will you [ __ ] finish me why is not
my job to finish you that is Bob's job
I'm here to complete Bob that is the
agreement that we had that is true I
just don't get why I can't come on that
had to be close I owe such a delicate
Boop of the button here we go here we go
here we go okay Bob get ready you're
about to get a fail oh all right get
ready for a face you're right I know
perlier i am aware the right why
what the [ __ ] oh that's getting closer
yeah chill stop waving it around
aim at me is that on you is that on you
that looks like it might be just a skosh
too far to your right
I know you can't really move it a skosh
I miss Coe she's act better that looks
as far as I can tell that looks pretty
accurate okay did it move when I changed
my hand yes it did no well it's close
it's before it twitches away it's not
your fault
that wasn't your fault you did good man
you did so good come on stay with I
think I've got a strategy I'm gonna
change up for it I just got a just got
to do it right a big a big part of it
for me is you got to get a good grasp on
the bow without [ __ ] everything yeah
I think grip of the bow is like king is
100 am I the first one loaded this time
yeah maybe
wait can you give me like a gauge on how
how aimed at you I am that looks dead on
and then give it a I'm gonna give it up
so what what what yeah that's the
problem they're hard
I thought grabbing it from the bottom
would be easier but it's it's not
grabbing it at all now No why do what
it's literally exactly out of my reach
that's how I like are you [ __ ]
kidding me that's custom huh I get it
I'm so smart I did it oh my god oh my
god I used I used a bolt to pull it back
haha
still in the game yeah I think we should
restart what no God I think everyone's
having a bad time wait no bolt let go no
let go Bob is good to you Bob a mile
it's just the smallest amount - you're
right
that looks so close to me that looks so
close Wade's a [ __ ] wizard you're
done Wade I've got the underhand grip
because I'm a genius that's how all
right you am oh look over no I don't
need I don't want him - this ghost whoa
what the hell what what what what the
[ __ ] all right what the [ __ ] what
happened I don't look happening my hand
is stuck on the table no what why though
but why I could kind of see it's like
cliff didn't do it
I'm trying to drag it out with my other
hand you might want to unload a bolt
before you tried for your hand no hang
on you're gonna lose them they're
[ __ ] out of here if you move too much
I don't care what happened to you care
what happens to me
oh [ __ ] that was almost sexy the way I
did that wait wait wait wait I might
have this can you push the button with
your right yeah I'm it's set up for that
holy [ __ ] you're wizard oh [ __ ] off
goddamn it just you wait whoa out here
we are you do new it at the end of all
things why why why why why why why
you're good you're good you're good
rotate there no I'm not good we got this
it's no good it just gets stuck what it
gets stuck I swear to god it just gets
stuck are you see what is happening I'm
not touching anything are you [ __ ]
kidding me are you [ __ ] kidding me if
your hand just moving back on its own
yeah it is I don't understand what's out
I think underhanded grip is just a curse
and it will not work for anybody
why are you caressing it with me because
I'm trying to trade hands Baba I don't
like the [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] curse it's [ __ ] stop
it's pointed at my own head and it's now
pointed at my own head and wants me to
shoot myself in my [ __ ] head this
isn't cursed but this is a cursed boat
I'm not joking this loaded up I'm just
gonna shoot myself because that's what
it wants I'm compelled the voices in my
head or just [ __ ] it what's my hand
doing what pardon
[Applause]
it's somehow cocked itself it was not
cocked a second ago already I prepared
myself one it's ileane to me you know
what I want you to show my hand is
shaking violently okay alright wait in
there I think this is gonna point back
at my own head but oh boy yeah okay I'm
so glad I'm dead for all this oh my god
it pulls back it's pulling back to my
own head it's it's doing anything it's
just it's trying aggressively to aim at
your own head yeah that I mean I there's
no other way to explain it this is this
is cursed very cool we just restarted
let's just restart I think we should
look at me what I can't honey who are
you you see only one that's alive I like
how you're holding it up with your other
high it takes way too hands to flick you
off no done this was fine take that -
Jesus oh yeah more of this it's it's for
the game is fine it's just maybe the
game's not fun but you know it's fine
[ __ ] my hand powers it's not cocking she
said all right wait help me with the aim
I'll put you out of your misery if you
if you give me a little cyst with the
aim here just let me let me at least
[ __ ] it oh my god you shoot you mark I
can try and shoot you no no don't shoot
me I'm in the middle of something
Bob aim very so slight that looks dead
on again coming in hot
yep that went right through me that was
reading my chesticles
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] my life hacker wait
over here
[Laughter]
why are you moving right it's moving
again it's moving again
I'm not what what what Bob what's
happening to me your face is really low
[Applause]
like six inches away are you guys seeing
what I'm seeing
let me pull this dream up my crossbow
the wing part of it the actual bow was
happening last round that was happening
last round a little bit to you I don't
see that on my end I see I only see the
oh your you don't have thingies anymore
no I don't know more yeah my crossbow
doesn't have those things that you don't
need those you don't need those you see
my fire this no they're gone those are
just gone
I wonder if I throw these if that would
be better than trying to load [ __ ]
funny actually alright my triage like
Hawk this like a spear hey you all right
mark
[ __ ] you ready for this [ __ ] mark yeah
please kill me look at that oh yeah yeah
that's okay now right now oh hang on
alright it's still in a good place I
know it went way up chill chill chill
bro that's so high stop that nonsense
I'm gonna try throw this at wait wait
wait it might be happening damn it kill
me kill me too on you Bob whoo
suck you're never gonna be able to shoot
mark you dick I will I have you have not
what do you have my god wait don't
I did wait I don't have a bow anymore
it's in your hand mark nope you you're
not seeing the bowl portion beam can you
not [ __ ] it cuz I know I see it being
broken you try and see what happens I
will see what happens
it looks like it still exists to me can
you see it I can't no I see nothing
there's right absolutely nothing you
were really close you're really close
slowly casually no I died just now did
you not kill me
no I marks are your doing nothing I did
nothing
it says Bobby's body killed you yeah
I've looked down into your arrow and
died my self in the head with my own
bolt it's not stabbing you won't go into
my face resting your eyebrows yeah I
can't die I can't die mark won I did
[ __ ] one
[Music]
you
[Music]